live camera this is on top of the bank
of america the moleski family companies
rainbow in the 95. now we're looking out
to the east so this is torrey pines as
it goes over the 95 so we're looking out
to the east definitely some stormy
looking clouds out there we're thinking
that the storms are going to be more
likely over the higher elevations can't
completely rule out something here in
town we're at 106 well actually that's
the forecast high officially it's only
95 out at reed international we may not
make this predicted high of 106 we got
cloud cover but we'll put that up there
as the forecast high the neighborhoods
all around town ranging between 95 and
about 100 out at nellis air force base
normal high for this time of year is 105
i don't know if you've noticed but the
sun is now going to bed each night
before 8 p.m after we had that longest
day of the year on the first day of
summer all right let's
dig into the future cast here by one
o'clock this afternoon as we mentioned
higher elevations much more likely to
see storms the valley remains dry here 2
p.m
maybe something going on up to the
spring mountains 3 p.m the same
definitely another storm cell again well
to the north of us now by 5 o'clock
there may be something going on a little
bit to the south around boulder city and
by the way some neighborhoods around
boulder city got close to an inch of
rain yesterday officially all we got was
1 100th so again high country storms are
more likely we can't completely rule out
some storms here in town for your family
and friends now across the country
this area of yellow that is a severe
thunderstorm watch for central montana a
line of severe storms now is moving
through the midwest and again the eight
day forecast we thought we'd be able to
dry it out for tomorrow we're going to
leave lingering storm clouds in for
tomorrow
again i don't know that we're going to
make 106 today but then we definitely
start warming up as the atmosphere
atmosphere dries out 110 for sunday and
then getting stuck in a 108 degree rut
you definitely have to watch out for
storms
not all neighborhoods are going to get
anything heather though so we'll keep an
eye on it for you an eye on the sky nate
thank you for watching out for